you know when you like think of an idea
and you like yeah this sounds good in my
head and then you come to do it and
you're just like what the [ __ ] was I
thinking
[Music]
hey guys so today I am going to explain
the plot of domestic girlfriend's after
I eat this uh this this [ __ ] ghost
pepper so um we're gonna we're gonna see
how spicy the plots gonna be after I
take a bite so um yeah here we go
this was this was such a bad idea oh my
god oh my god so domestic domestic
girlfriend starts up with a guy not to
work dope
there come the hiccups salsa for the guy
not someone honey he's things where they
go good boy and he does that because
he's trying to forget yeah yeah she
loves which is teacher he's did she call
here oh my god and so he's in love with
his teacher and he sleeps with another
random girl
and his dad's getting remarried and he
finds out back the person who's getting
married to is the mother oh my god it
keeps getting worse ha ha ha ha the
person he's gay magic is the mother of
good+ nice Leblon and his teacher and he
finds out he was getting having an
affair with a married man
the married man and stop it and and he's
he turns out tonguing her and Hina stops
him and he was just like I don't you
pushes it down anyway let's not tell you
oh oh my god this is so hot this is so
hot and then and Hina starts where was I
and then really starts Mari finds out
about the affair and then they they try
to stop Hina from having having the
affair and then and then and then rui
[ __ ] throw some water on the guy and
then um
and then it's just everyone [ __ ]
watching each other
my mother comes in she's had so much
semen go cheese goes on so much semen
but she's such a sweetheart this
supposed Tori scene oh that's where has
the first repository to do anything
[Music]
you must come on the anime mostly not so
you confess this tahina properly and he
knows like if you want to be with me you
got to die bro you got a double suicide
with me and now so doesn't want to do
that then breweries like holy o brew is
like hey bro do you want to tongue now
she's like yeah sure why not my other
sister wanna get with me I said it's not
tonguing I mean off that's done now so I
walks in on a really touching scene with
Hina my touching I mean not sorry start
talking a bit more nobody's know what
his house leaves their door what so he
sees she's like she's like right [ __ ]
he's your brother and then raised like
it's this doll related by blood
[Music]
good are you right dude are you [ __ ]
one oh my god and then uh and so that
that I go and so it turns out all along
patina like knots whoa all this time and
she was just pretending and um yeah they
start getting out and having China
having a proper relationship she moves
out they start [ __ ] kissing they stop
[ __ ] kissing in the hallway of of the
school I hoping no one will find out
it's the boys awful secret like ship of
all time I think that's everyone I think
that's everything that sounds good me
I'm oh oh Jesus I never want to do that
again in my life you know just describe
the fall after having a [ __ ] ghost
pepper god [ __ ] great idea why don't
why why did I never why did I not think
of that before
Oh
did you enjoy that if you enjoyed the
domestic college overview blow me on
patreon use my coupon code a book woke
up whatever the [ __ ] you want just leave
me with this milk alright